Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I wish you could swim like dolphins like dolphins can swim. The opening lines of David Bowie's great song Heroes. I apologise for not singing it. I'm just not equal to doing that. It was recorded in 1977 when David Bowie was living in West Berlin, hanging out with Iggy Pop.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们深受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我希望你能像海豚那样游泳，像海豚那样游泳。大卫·鲍伊（David Bowie）伟大歌曲《英雄》（Heroes）的开场白。为我没有唱出来而道歉。我只是觉得力不从心。这首歌录制于1977年，当时大卫·鲍伊住在西柏林，和伊基·波普（Iggy Pop）混在一起。
And of course, the lyrics famously name check the Berlin Wall. But for me, I think it's that opening that is the most haunting. Because in July 1977, the same month that Bowie began recording Heroes, the body of an East Berliner, Henry Weisser, was found on the Marshall Bridge water border in Berlin-Mitte. He'd been dead for two months. He'd almost certainly died trying to cross the River Spree from East Berlin into West Berlin and had died while doing so. And it's hard not to think that his fate didn't influence Bowie's idea of the lovers separated by the wall. If only he'd been able to swim like a dolphin. And I think, Dominic, the Berlin Wall is a great theme for a podcast this August because it's the 60th anniversary of its building.
当然，这首歌的歌词中著名的提到了柏林墙。但对我来说，我认为最让人难以忘怀的是那个开场。因为在1977年7月，也就是鲍伊开始录制《英雄》的同一个月，柏林米特的马歇尔桥水界上发现了一具东柏林人亨利·威瑟（Henry Weisser）的尸体。他已经死了两个月了。他几乎可以肯定是在试图从东柏林横渡施普雷河进入西柏林时溺水身亡的。你很难不认为他的命运影响了鲍伊关于被墙隔开的情侣的想法。要是他能像海豚一样游泳就好了。多米尼克，我认为柏林墙是今年8月播客的一个绝佳主题，因为今年是它修建60周年。
I think it actually the 13th of August is when it began. As a historian of the modern world, I mean, in a way, the Berlin Wall, I mean, it served as a symbol for the Cold War, but also its coming down serves as a symbol of the end of the Cold War. It did. You're absolutely right. I think it's extraordinary, isn't it, when you look back? I think the Berlin Wall is one of the hardest things to explain to people who are too young to remember it. So I think you can explain the Cold War, but that sort of sense of the divided city and just the colossal iconographic importance of the Berlin Wall. I mean, for people like us who grew up in the sort of 70s and 80s, the Berlin Wall, I mean, the weird thing is it kind of was an it kind of was an obscenity and a symbol of, you know,
我认为实际上是8月13日开始的。作为一个现代世界历史学家，从某种意义上说，柏林墙不仅是冷战的象征，而且它的倒塌也成为了冷战结束的象征。确实如此。你绝对说得对，回想起来，你不觉得这很不可思议吗？我认为，柏林墙是向那些太年轻而记不清它的人解释时最难解释的事情之一。所以你可以解释冷战，但那种城市被分裂的感觉，以及柏林墙巨大的图腾般的重要性。对于像我们这样在70年代和80年代长大的人来说，柏林墙的怪异之处在于，它某种程度上是一种猥亵物，是……的象征
the sort of madness and terror of the Cold War. But at the same time, it had always been there in our lives. So it was just part of the sort of- Yeah, you took it for granted. You completely took it for granted. And so the weirdness was when it wasn't there. Precisely. The idea, I mean, to me, there was always West Berlin and East Berlin.
冷战的疯狂和恐怖。但与此同时，它一直存在于我们的生活中，所以它只是那种——是的，你把它视为理所当然。你完全把它视为理所当然。所以奇怪的是它不在的时候。确切地说。我的意思是，对我来说，一直都有西柏林和东柏林。
They appeared in Bond films. They were part of the sort of conversation. And that moment when the Berlin Wall came down and there would be one Berlin and one Germany, that was the weird bit because I'd always known nothing but West Germany, East Germany, East Berlin and so on. I mean, it's an extraordinary thing to get your head around. And imagine a wall like that in London or Paris or something. It's mind-boggling. But it happened in the capital of modern Germany,
它们出现在007电影中。它们是那种对话的一部分。柏林墙倒塌的那一刻，将只有一个柏林和一个德国，那是奇怪的部分，因为我只知道西德、东德、东柏林等等。我的意思是，这是一件让人难以理解的 extraordinay 事情。想象一下在伦敦、巴黎或其他地方有这样一堵墙。这太匪夷所思了。但它发生在现代德国的首都，
one of the most dynamic and exciting cities now in the world. Well, so it's a great theme. And we need the author of a great book to take us through it. And very fortunately, we have Ian McGregor, the author of Checkpoint Charlie, a book about the Berlin Wall with us. Ian, thanks so much for coming on the podcast. So you've written about the Berlin Wall, so you've been thinking about it for a long, long time. Do you feel kind of divorced now from the strangeness of it? Or are there still moments where you go, wow, that's odd?
现在世界上最具活力和令人兴奋的城市之一。好吧，这是一个很棒的主题。我们需要一本好书的作者来带我们了解它。非常幸运的是，我们请到了《查理检查哨》（Checkpoint Charlie）一书的作者伊恩·麦格雷戈（Ian McGregor）和我们在一起，这本书是关于柏林墙的。伊恩，非常感谢你来参加播客。所以你写过关于柏林墙的书，所以你思考了很长时间。你现在觉得自己和它的怪异感脱节了吗？还是仍然有些时刻让你觉得，哇，这太奇怪了？
Oh, yeah. I mean, I'm pretty much the same age as you guys. So just what Dominic says, I mean, he basically took the words out of my mouth. I grew up with the permanence of not just the Berlin Wall, but obviously of the intra-German border, which we can talk about later, and the physicality of it. To me, growing up, lover of history since I was 11, it was as permanent as the Himalayas. It was just never going to go away.
哦，是的。我的意思是，我和你们年龄差不多。所以正如多米尼克所说，他基本上说出了我想说的话。我在不仅仅是柏林墙的永恒中长大，显然还有两德边界的永恒，我们稍后可以讨论，还有它的实体感。对我来说，作为一个从11岁起就热爱历史的人，它就像喜马拉雅山一样永恒。它永远不会消失。
So, yeah, I'm a bit of a Cold War, Berlin Wall, Berlin City geek, because that's what I was brought up on. I mean, I've had my father and various relatives all served in the British Army of the Rhine from the 1950s onwards. So that's weird, isn't it? The British Army on the Rhine from the 1950s onwards. Yeah, so that's weird, isn't it? The British Army on the Rhine. It's all so odd. And yet we all just took it for granted. Yeah, so I just grew up on their stories. And my dad, he was never stationed in Berlin, but he obviously had R&R trips there.
所以，是的，我有点像个冷战、柏林墙、柏林市的极客，因为我就是伴随着这些长大的。我的意思是，我的父亲和各种亲戚从20世纪50年代起都在英国莱茵集团军服役。所以这很奇怪，不是吗？英国莱茵集团军从20世纪50年代开始。是的，所以这很奇怪，不是吗？英国莱茵集团军。这一切都太奇怪了。然而我们都认为这是理所当然的。是的，我只是听着他们的故事长大的。我爸爸从来没有驻扎在柏林，但他显然去那里进行过R&R（休假）旅行。
So I had the excitement of him wide-eyed telling me what it was like, the bright lights and everything, the American sector and all the things you could buy and things like that. Even a British squad he couldn't buy that you could go into the American PX stores and that kind of thing. And then younger uncles who were there in the 70s and then the early 80s. So by then I was studying for A-level history and it was always going to be about modern European history and the Cold War. So and then I was lucky enough to go to East Germany as well. And I went to the Soviet Union in 81 on school exchange trips. So there was only if I was ever going to write a book because this is my proper first book, even though I'm a publisher, it was always going to be about this because it was the thing that was always bubbling up inside me.
所以我兴奋地听他瞪大眼睛告诉我那里是什么样子，耀眼的灯光和一切，美国区以及你可以买到的所有东西之类的。甚至连一个英国士兵也买不到，你可以去美国PX商店买那种东西。然后是70年代和80年代初在那里的更年轻的叔叔们。所以到那时我正在学习A-level历史，它注定是关于现代欧洲历史和冷战的。所以，然后我很幸运地去了东德。我在81年通过学校交流旅行去了苏联。所以如果我要写一本书，因为这是我的第一本正经的书，尽管我是一个出版商，它也注定是关于这个的，因为这是我内心一直在涌动的东西。
And I knew how I wanted to tackle it and the people I'd like to talk to. So give us a sense of I mean,, we do have, amazingly to Tom and me, we actually have some young listeners for whom all this is absolute ancient history. So maybe we should talk a bit about the context, because actually the context of this originally is not really so much the Cold War as the Second World War. It's the fact that the two pincers of the Allied advance, you know, that the Russians get to Berlin first. And then there's this question of what's going to happen to Berlin and what's going to happen to Germany.
我知道我想怎么处理它，以及我想和什么样的人交谈。所以给我们一种感觉——我的意思是，对汤姆和我来说惊奇的是，我们确实有一些年轻听众，对他们来说这一切都是绝对的古代历史。所以也许我们应该谈谈背景，因为实际上这背后的背景与其说是冷战，不如说是第二次世界大战。这是盟军进攻的两把钳子，你知道的，俄国人首先到达柏林。然后就有了柏林会发生什么以及德国会发生什么的问题。
So talk us through a bit of that background. Well, Stalin obviously was throwing a few bogus decisions or ideas, I suppose, to the Allies, especially to Eisenhower, saying Berlin had lost its strategic importance to the Soviet Red Army's thrust into Europe. But to them, it was always the goal. The main goal was to capture the heart of Hitler's Reich. And there's a very important comment or line that his foreign secretary Molotov said just after the end of the Second World War. Well, it was about 46 where he'd said, what happens to Berlin happens to Germany, and what happens to Germany happens to Europe. And he said that just after the end of the Second World War. And that shows you exactly what the Russians thought of Berlin, its place in Germany, and obviously Germany's place to the Soviet plan in Europe.
所以给我们讲讲这些背景。嗯，斯大林显然向盟军，特别是向艾森豪威尔抛出了一些虚假的决定或想法，我猜，说柏林对苏联红军向欧洲挺进的战略重要性已经失去了。但对他们来说，这始终是目标。主要目标是占领希特勒帝国的核心。他的外交大臣莫洛托夫在二战结束刚过不久说过一句非常重要的话或台词。嗯，大约是46年，他说过，柏林发生的事情就会在德国发生，德国发生的事情就会在欧洲发生。他在第二次世界大战刚结束不久就这么说了。这确切地向你展示了俄国人对柏林的看法，它在德国的地位，以及显然德国对苏联在欧洲计划的地位。
Now they'd obviously marched westward, right up to the Elbe River, where the demarcation was going to be for the Allies. That had been the agreement, as in that's where the Red Army would stop, and that's where the Allies coming from the west would stop too. And then they would sit down and have their discussion on how they were going to occupy and govern the country and denazify it to where it was going to be a stable governing democracy in inverted commas. And that's what would happen at Potsdam, the Potsdam Conference in July. So obviously, end of the war is May 1945. By July, the Russians had already been in control of Berlin. And that's when the Allies were allowed
现在他们显然向西行军，一直到达易北河，盟军的分界线将设在那里。这就是协议，也就是红军将在那里停止，从西方来的盟军也将在那里停止。然后他们将坐下来讨论他们将如何占领和治理这个国家，并进行去纳粹化，使其成为一个稳定的民选民主国家（打引号）。这就是波茨坦会议（7月的波茨坦会议）上将要发生的事情。所以显而易见，战争结束于1945年5月。到了7月，俄国人已经控制了柏林。那时盟军被允许
to actually then enter the city in July, two months later. And what went on in the country and in the city itself under Russian occupation has been covered by the likes of Max Hastings and the atrocities that were committed, etc, etc. But by July, the Russians were wholesale looting and pillaging and taking anything they could lay their hands on to ship back to the mother country to help rebuild their destroyed infrastructure, which has had colossal destruction wrought on it by the Wehrmacht. So at Potsdam, that's where the agreement was that the country would then be split into zones of occupation. It was originally only going to be what was seen by the Russians as the victorious allies, which were going to be themselves, the Russians,
在7月，也就是两个月后，实际进入该市。在俄国占领下，这个国家和城市本身发生了什么，马克斯·哈斯廷斯（Max Hastings）等人已经做了报道，包括所犯下的暴行等等。但到了7月，俄国人正在大肆掠夺、劫掠，拿走他们能弄到的任何东西，运回祖国，以帮助重建被德意志国防军造成巨大破坏的基础设施。所以在波茨坦，达成了协议，即国家将被分割为占领区。最初它只被俄国人视为胜利的盟军，也就是他们自己（俄国人），
the Americans and the British. de Gaulle from France put up a protest and obviously it was deemed necessary for real politic that the French were involved. So the Americans and the British gave up some of their territory that would be under French control, obviously on their border. So the overall plan to have four zones of occupation for the country was then mirrored for Berlin itself, which obviously was seen as the capital of the country. So therefore, it was deemed necessary that there would be four zones
美国人和英国人。法国的戴高乐提出了抗议，显然从现实政治来看，法国人参与进来被认为是必要的。因此，美国人和英国人放弃了部分将受法国控制的领土，显然在他们的边境上。因此，将国家划分为四个占领区的总体计划，随后也在柏林本身得到了反映，柏林显然被视为国家的首都。因此，人们认为有必要设立四个区
of occupation for the city itself. And obviously French, American, British and the Soviet zone. And that's the way it was as we were then going through into the late 40s. And what could then be seen would be the Allies strenuously trying to evolve their sections of Germany itself and their sections of Berlin itself into a fully functioning, democratic, civilian-led government. Just how far is Berlin from the frontier of the Western zone? It's 177 kilometres, so roughly 100 miles. So that's an island, isn't it? Island of democracy, you could say, inside the Soviet zone of occupation. There were links, obviously.
城市本身的占领。显然有法国、美国、英国和苏联占领区。这就是我们进入40年代末时的状况。然后可以看到的是，盟军正在努力将他们自己负责的德国部分和柏林部分演变成一个全面运转的、民主的、平民领导的政府。柏林距离西方占领区的边境有多远？是177公里，大约100英里。所以那是一座孤岛，不是吗？可以说，在苏联占领区内有一座民主孤岛。当然有联系。
It was never a formal agreement. This was allowed by Stalin in discussions. It was never actually signed documents that I could find in the archives or when I was talking to various commanders who were in charge of the Allied garrisons. There was a road demarcation from Helmsdorf on the east-west German border that led into West Berlin. There were three Allied air corridors. And then obviously there were various canal routes that would take shipping in and out of the city itself,
这从来都不是一项正式协议。这是斯大林在讨论中允许的。这从来都不是我能在档案馆里找到的实际签署的文件，或者当我与负责盟军卫戍部队的各种指挥官交谈时。从东西德边境的赫尔姆斯多夫（Helmsdorf）有一条通往西柏林的公路分界线。有三条盟军空中走廊。然后显然有各种运河航线，可以把船只运进运出城市本身，
all to supply the city. Because like you just said, it was an island within the Soviet zone that had to be supplied by the Western allies from the Western zones. So Ian, there's no legal framework governing that. The various corridors, the road corridors, the rail corridors, the air corridors, because obviously this is key to the story and the survival of West Berlin. And as the Cold War starts to get chilly, what is stopping Stalin from just cutting them?
都是为了给城市提供物资。因为就像你刚才说的，它是苏联占领区内的一个孤岛，必须由西方盟友从西方占领区提供物资。所以伊恩，没有管理它的法律框架。各种走廊、公路走廊、铁路走廊、空中走廊，因为这显然是故事的关键和西柏林的生存。随着冷战开始变冷，是什么阻止了斯大林直接切断它们？
The fear of a third world war? Is that the only thing that stops him? Yes, I would imagine so, because he obviously wanted a unified, weak Germany, because in that way, he would probably eventually have what was going on in the other eastern countries that the Soviets were occupying, as in Czechoslovakia, Poland, Hungary, Romania, Bulgaria, they all fell eventually, in the throughout the middle to late 40s, to what basically is communist coups that were taking over so that the actual civilian elections that were being held, were gerrymandered, and Soviet, Soviet, sympathetic governments installed. The answer, obviously, to Stalin and the Kremlin. That's what he wanted for Germany.
对第三次世界大战的恐惧？是唯一阻止他的东西吗？是的，我想是的，因为他显然想要一个统一的、软弱的德国，因为那样的话，他最终可能会拥有苏联在其他东方国家正在发生的事情，比如捷克斯洛伐克、波兰、匈牙利、罗马尼亚、保加利亚，它们最终都在40年代中后期沦陷，基本上是共产党政变接管，使实际举行的民选选举被操纵，并安装了亲苏、亲苏联的政府。答案显然对斯大林和克里姆林宫来说是这样的。这就是他对德国的想要。
He wanted the Allies out. He didn't want a military presence that he still saw as a capitalist enemy within Germany. He would rather have everyone out, and then eventually, through hook or by crook, through the back door, you'd soviet uh takeover of the government eventually uh it wasn't in his interest to have uh a big military camp in uh west germany or in west berlin which is what it was by 1948 49 obviously the cold war becomes you know more intense the the mutual suspicion grows um effectively relations break down and then and then i mean you've got the berlin airlift where berlin is kind of sealed off and the allies so that's 49 is it
他想要盟军离开。他不想在德国境内保留他仍然视为资本主义敌人的军事存在。他宁愿每个人都离开，然后最终通过各种手段，通过后门，最终由苏维埃接管政府……到1948、1949年，在西德或西柏林拥有一个庞大的军事营地不符合他的利益，显然冷战变得（你知道的）更加激烈，相互猜疑加剧，实际上关系破裂，然后……然后你有柏林空运，柏林基本上被封锁了，盟军……所以那是49年，对吧？
49 48 49 yeah yeah 48 48 june 48 to may 49 and then you have this intervening period where where where there is no berlin war but well there's a sort of intellectual and and cultural berlin war but not a physical one and what's going on there are people just fleeing across the across the border into west berlin and then through can they get from west berlin into west germany how does that work well yeah i mean they they right up until about 1952 you could still get over the the west uh west german east german border anyway i mean you could still get over the West German, East German border anyway. I mean, you could get through it. You had to be very, very careful.
49、48、49，是的，是的，48年48月到49年5月，然后你有一个介入期，在那里没有柏林墙，但……嗯，有一种知识和文化的柏林墙，但不是实体的。那里的情况如何？人们只是越过边境逃往西柏林，然后通过……他们能从西柏林去西德吗？那是怎么运作的？好吧，是的，我的意思是——直到大约1952年，你仍然可以越过西德、东德边境。无论如何，我的意思是，你仍然可以越过西德、东德边境。我的意思是，你可以通过它。你必须非常、非常小心。
And a great many people were arrested and imprisoned. A few people were shot, but not many. So it was possible. But the crux came really in 1953, where you had the East German workers rose up protesting about their pay, their working conditions, the lack of consumer goods to buy anything, just what a hard life they were living. And what became like a localized uprising in Berlin ended up spreading across the whole of East Germany, which was only put down within a week or so by Russian tanks and obviously the KGB helping out the East German government as well to take out the various protesters, thousands of people in prison.
很多人被捕入狱。少数人被枪杀，但不多。所以这是可能的。但关键其实出现在1953年，当时你经历了东德工人起事，抗议他们的工资、工作条件、缺乏买东西的消费品，以及他们过着多么艰难的生活。在柏林演变成局部起义的事件最终蔓延到了整个东德，仅仅在一周左右的时间里就被苏联坦克平息了，显然克格勃也协助东德政府抓捕了各种抗议者，数千人入狱。
And from that point onwards, it was very much a much more hard-headed approach the East German government had to their own citizens about what they could do, their freedom of movement, where they're allowed to go, to stop them obviously going. But to the East German citizenship, what had been a trickle up until 52, 53, if people wanted to build a new life in the West because they might be unhappy living in East Germany, became a flood. So you're looking at thousands every week getting through the border. And the one border that was possible to get through pretty much unmolested,
从那时起，东德政府对他们自己的公民采取了一种更强硬的态度，关于他们能做什么、他们的行动自由、他们被允许去哪里，以阻止他们显然离开。但对于东德公民来说，一直到52、53年还只是涓涓细流——如果人们想在西方建立新生活，因为他们可能对在东德的生活不满意——变成了一场洪水。所以你看到每周有成千上万的人穿过边境。唯一一条基本上可以毫发无损地穿过的边境，
if you knew what you were doing, was Berlin. Because what you had again was you had the four occupation zones were still intact, but they were unmarked borders. And by unmarked, what I mean is there wasn't a hard border, there wasn't armed guards there that were checking every single person that was going through. Because what your younger listeners have to remember is, especially if they live in a city or a big town, if they think about where they have to go to every day to get to go and do things, whether it's going to the dentist, going to school, their parents going to work,
如果你知道你在做什么，那就是柏林。因为你再次拥有的是四个占领区仍然完好无所谓，但它们是未标明的边境。所谓未标明，我的意思是那里没有硬边界，那里没有武装警卫检查每一个过境的人。因为你们年轻的听众必须记住的是，特别是如果他们住在城市或大镇，如果他们想想他们每天必须去哪里去做事情，无论是去牙医那里、去学校，他们的父母去上班，
they might crisscross across these towns and cities as everyone does. Everyone does in London, whether it's on the bus, the tube, et cetera. That's what was going on in Berlin. Even though it was East and West Berlin, there were zones of occupation, East Berliners under the Soviet zone could still travel to work in West Berlin. They could still go to the hospital or they could go and see relatives or friends. And that was the loophole. So if you're very clever and careful and you're not obviously showing
他们可能会像每个人一样穿梭于这些城镇和城市之间。每个人在伦敦都会这样，无论是在公共汽车上、地铁上等等。柏林当时就是这样。尽管有东西柏林之分，但仍有占领区，苏联占领区下的东柏林人仍然可以去西柏林上班。他们仍然可以去医院，或者去看望亲戚或朋友。这就是漏洞。所以如果你非常聪明和谨慎，并且没有表现出来
you're carrying all your belongings to leave your life in East Germany, that's how you get across. And obviously lots of people were stopped, but thousands upon thousands of people managed to escape to a new life. And I mean, we're not skipping too far forward, but by 1961 and we're getting to the war,
你带着所有的随身物品离开你在东德的生活，这就是你如何过境的。显然很多人被拦下了，但成千上万的人设法逃向了新生活。我的意思是，我们并没有跳得太远，但到了1961年，当我们走到那场战争时，
2.1 million East Germans had fled to the West. Can I ask you then, so say the summer of 1961, I'm sure this is a really it's an impossible question, but I want to ask it anyway. Do you have a sense of how many what percentage of people in East Germany are true believers in communism? And what percentage are people who are desperate to get out? Well, I think you'd have to look at, if you talk about the latter, the latter is easy to look at because you look at statistics. Like I said, 2.1 million had left by 1961, and that's a sixth of the population. And from that sixth of the population, 50% of them were under 25 years old.
210万东德人逃往西方。那我能问你吗，比方说1961年夏天，我确信这是一个非常……这是一个不可能的问题，但无论如何我都想问。你有没有一种感觉，东德有多少人、百分之多少人是共产主义的真正信徒？又有多少百分比的人是急于离开的？好吧，我想你必须看看，如果你谈论后者，后者很容易看，因为你可以看统计数据。就像我说的，到1961年，有210万人离开，这占人口的六分之一。在这六分之一的人口中，50%的人在25岁以下。
And the bulk of them too were from the professional classes. So you'd leave if you were ambitious, right? Exactly. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean, higher education. So the socialist dream that they were trying to build was very much you'll have free education right up to university level.
其中绝大多数也来自专业阶层。所以如果你有雄心壮志，你就会离开，对吧？完全正确。是的，是的，是的。我的意思是，高等教育。因此，他们试图建立的社会主义梦想很大程度上是，你将获得直到大学水平的免费教育。
You'll have a job for life because you'll be going into pre-planned occupations. That's fine. But as Dominic just said, if you have plans, because who knows really what they want to do when you're a student. So if you even diverge slightly from the official storyline of where your career might go or where your life might go, you were deemed a threat to the ruling party, the ruling government, society in general in East Germany. And obviously, we can talk about the heavy surveillance they had on the population in terms of the stars, the operatives, the secret police. But like I said, 50% were under 25.
你将拥有一份终身工作，因为你将进入预先规划的职业。这很好。但正如多米尼克刚才所说，如果你有计划，因为当你还是个学生时，谁真正知道自己想做什么呢。因此，如果你甚至稍微偏离了你的职业可能走向或你的生活可能走向的官方故事情节，你就会被视为对东德的统治党、统治政府、整个社会的威胁。显然，我们可以讨论他们在情报人员、特工、秘密警察方面的对人口的严密监视。但就像我说的，50%的人在25岁以下。
That's the lifeblood of any economy. If they're departing to go and start a new life in the West, it's a brain drain. It's an economic drain on the East German experiment surviving economically. And so the true believers, the true believers. True believers. Well, I mean, at any one time, again, if you look at the statistics and you listen to when you're talking to East Germans themselves, I'd say I interviewed over 50 East Germans for my book. And I'd say at least half of them were, I wouldn't say true believers in the purest sense, but they believed in the system they were in until they ran into problems further down the line as their lives were developing and they wanted their careers to grow. So I talked to people that were in the East German socialist version of the Hitler Youth, so to speak, that believed completely and believed the war was necessary. But by the time we get to the 1980s, and they're seeing their restrictions more and more curtailed, especially in travel, they'd become very cynical and wanted to change the system and wanted to get out of the country. So I'd say not even 10% were true believers.
那是任何经济的生命线。如果他们离开去西方开始新生活，这就是人才流失。这对东德实验在经济上的生存来说是一场经济上的流失。所以真正的信徒，真正的信徒。真正的信徒。好吧，我的意思是，在任何特定时间，同样，如果你看看统计数据，听听你与东德人自己的交谈，我会说我为我的书采访了50多名东德人。我会说至少有一半人——我不会说在最纯粹意义上的真正信徒，但他们相信他们所处的系统，直到他们在生活发展的后期遇到问题，希望他们的职业发展。所以我跟那些加入过东德社会主义版“希特勒青年团”的人聊过，可以说，他们完全相信，并认为这场战争是必要的。但到了20世纪80年代，他们看到自己的限制越来越多地被削减，特别是在旅行方面，他们变得非常愤世嫉俗，想要改变体制并想离开这个国家。所以我想说，连10%的真正信徒都没有。
But how many of us are ever true believers in anything? I mean, it's like saying we live in the Western world of capitalism and democracy, but how many of us would say, yeah, I'm a really true believer. I think about it all the time. And I love our system. I mean, that's not really, I suppose they just muddled along, didn't they? Until they, a lot of people just muddle along. Well, I'm not sure that's true because communism is, I mean, it's a faith. It's something that you feel is changing the world for the better. So in a sense, it does imply a kind of ideological commitment in a way that perhaps a commitment to the right to buy goods isn't quite the same way.
但我们当中有多少人真正相信任何东西呢？我的意思是，这就像说我们生活在资本主义和民主的西方世界，但我们当中有多少人会说，是的，我真的是个坚定的信徒。我一直都在想这个。我热爱我们的体制。我的意思是，这其实不是……我想他们只是混日子，不是吗？直到他们……很多人只是混日子。嗯，我不确定这是真的，因为共产主义是——我的意思是，它是一种信仰。它是你觉得能让世界变得更好的东西。所以在某种程度上，它确实暗示了一种意识形态的承诺，也许对购买商品的权利的承诺并不是完全一样的。
But I was going to say, I mean, one of one of the key interviews I had in the book, a guy called Professor Stefan Voller. That's his title now. And he's director of the GDR Museum on Museum Island in Berlin. It's one of the best Cold War museums in Germany. And to see what life was really like in East Germany. Very, very intelligent man, obviously, a bestselling author. He wrote the very first book of what life was like after the war came down. He told what life was like as he'd been growing up as a number one bestseller. But anyway, his father was on the East German Politburo, so to speak, and was an economist. And Stefan grew up in that atmosphere and he was a believer. He did his national service in the East German army.
但我要说的是，我的意思是，我在书中进行的其中一个关键采访，是一个叫斯特凡·沃勒（Stefan Voller）教授的人。那是他现在的头衔。他是柏林博物馆岛德意志民主共和国博物馆的馆长。这是德国最好的冷战博物馆之一。去看看东德的生活到底是什么样的。非常非常聪明的人，显然是畅销书作家。他写了关于柏林墙倒塌后生活是什么样的第一本书。他讲述了自己作为一个畅销书作家长大的生活是怎样的。无论如何，他的父亲曾在东德政治局任职，是一名经济学家。斯特凡就是在这种氛围中长大的，他是一个信徒。他在东德军队服役。
He was seen as one of the brightest students that they had. He was allowed to travel to Moscow to study. But gradually, as he's seeing the erosion of civil liberties increase, especially by the 80s, and he's seeing some of his friends being in prison, he's seeing some of his friends escape, the veil is pulled apart. And he might be sitting down and having lots of arguments with his father by this time. And that's what he was talking to me about, saying, you know, by the 81, 82, so that's seven years before the war came down, he was firmly, firmly against the regime. He just didn't know how it would end and how he could possibly effectively bring about change. He was just as surprised as the war coming down as anyone else.
他被视为他们拥有的最聪明的学生之一。他被允许去莫斯科学习。但渐渐地，随着他看到公民自由受到的侵蚀不断增加，特别是在80年代，他看到他的一些朋友入狱，他看到他的一些朋友逃跑，面纱被撕裂了。到这个时候，他可能坐下来和父亲发生了很激烈的争论。这就是他跟我谈论的，他说，你知道，到了81、82年，也就是柏林墙倒塌前七年，他坚定不移地反对这个政权。他只是不知道它将如何结束，以及他如何才能有效地带来改变。他和其他人一样对柏林墙倒塌感到惊讶。
So let's go back to 61. Yeah, sorry. So the summer of 61. So what's the thinking in the sort of East German high command? So they're seeing, obviously, they must have a sense of numbers. They must get a sense that all these people, and do they just think this is utterly intolerable? We have to do something and this is the obvious thing to do?
所以让我们回到61年。是的，抱歉。所以61年夏天。那么东德高层内部的想法是什么？所以他们看到，显然，他们一定对数字有所感知。他们一定感觉到所有人，他们只是觉得这完全不可容忍吗？我们必须做点什么，这是显而易见的事情？
Or is there a real debate within the regime about the wall? Do some of them see the PR disaster that it will be? Well, Walter Ulbricht, who was the leader of East Germany, had been from the late 40s, really. And by the mid 50s, was the de facto leader, recognized as such. He'd been arguing since probably 56, once Stalin had gone and Nikita Khrushchev had taken over and given his famous speech behind closed doors of what a tragedy it had been for Russia that Stalin had been in charge, et cetera, et cetera, jumping ahead. But it was seen that there could be some kind of more open relationship
还是政权内部对于柏林墙存在真正的辩论？他们中是否有人看到了它将带来的公关灾难？嗯，沃尔特·乌布利希（Walter Ulbricht），自40年代后期以来一直是东德的领导人。到50年代中期，他成为了事实上的领导人，并被公认为如此。他可能从56年就开始争论了，一旦斯大林走了，尼基塔·赫鲁晓夫接任并在闭门会议上发表了著名的演讲，讲述斯大林掌权对俄罗斯来说是一场悲剧，等等，等等（跳过）。但人们认为可以建立某种更公开的关系
between the East German government and the Kremlin. So instead of a one-way traffic of orders, you will do this, you will do that, Ulbricht was allowed to obviously regularly visit the Kremlin, sit down with Khrushchev and tell him his problems. And they're all very aware. They're looking at the statistics. They're seeing this flood, this migratory flood
在东德政府和克里姆林宫之间。因此，乌布利希不再是单向的命令交通——你会这样做，你会那样做，而是被允许定期访问克里姆林宫，与赫鲁晓夫坐在一起，告诉他他的问题。他们都很清楚。他们看着统计数据。他们看到了这场洪水，移民的洪水
of East Germans going to the West. So from I would say from 57 onwards, Ulbricht was constantly telling Khrushchev something needs to be done. And he was hoping it would be done on a more strategic level, that Khrushchev would win some kind of concessions from the Allies, where there might be a harder border along East and West Germany, as well as in Berlin itself, that would make it difficult for the East German citizenship to escape. These kind of things weren't happening. So by the time you're getting to 61, and like I said, by then a sixth of the population has just disappeared to the West. It was really crunch time. I mean, I would imagine, again, having talked to various people at the time and looked in the archives, they were probably only a year away
东德人前往西方。所以我可以说从57年开始，乌布利希一直在告诉赫鲁晓夫必须做点什么。他希望能在更具战略的层面上完成这一目标，即赫鲁晓夫将从盟军那里赢得某种让步，在东西德沿线以及柏林本身可能会有一条更硬的边界，这将使东德公民难以逃跑。这些事情并没有发生。所以到了61年，就像我说的，当时有六分之一的人口刚刚消失在西方。这真的是紧要关头。我的意思是，我想象，再次与当时的不同人交谈并在档案馆中查找，他们可能只有一年之遥
from economic collapse if something hadn't been done by that time. And obviously to the Allies, they're thinking this is great. Welcome aboard. Just come on in because we know what's going to happen. So there was that. But then, as we'll talk about the 61, it was just almost like a perfect storm of you've got a new American leader in John F. Kennedy. You've got Khrushchev coming to the table, very much more belligerent than he had
如果没有在那时采取行动，经济就会崩溃。显然对盟军来说，他们认为这太棒了。欢迎登船。快进来，因为我们知道会发生什么。所以有那种情况。但随后，正如我们稍后将讨论的61年事件，这几乎就像是一场完美的风暴：你有一个新的美国领导人约翰·F·肯尼迪。你让赫鲁晓夫来到谈判桌前，比以前好战得多，
been before because he knew it was crunch time because he was being told this by these Germans. And to him, just as much as the Americans had their domino theory about democratic states falling to the communists, Khrushchev had this fear keeping him up at night thinking, well, if I allow East Germany to fall, what's going to happen to Poland, Czechoslovakia, Hungary, et cetera, et cetera. I can't have this happening on my watch. So it's a decision for the Russians as much as it is for the East Germans. No, it was always a decision for the Russians, just as it would be in 89. So the East Germans can't do anything unless they get the green light. They wouldn't have moved a muscle.
因为他知道这是紧要关头，因为东德人就是这么告诉他的。对他来说，就像美国人对民主国家沦为共产主义国家有多米诺骨牌理论一样，赫鲁晓夫也有这种恐惧让他夜不能寐，心想，好吧，如果我允许东德沦落，波兰、捷克斯洛伐克、匈牙利等等会发生什么？我不能在我的任期内让这种事情发生。所以这对俄国人来说是一个决定，对东德人来说也是一样。不，这总是俄国人的决定，89年也是如此。所以东德人在没有得到绿灯的情况下什么也做不了。他们连一根手指都不会动。
They wouldn't have moved a muscle. They could have done, but they wouldn't have had the backing. Because the key thing is, in East Germany, you've got over 300,000 Red Army troops. You've got over 3,000 Russian tanks, the Air Force, et cetera, et cetera. That's what's keeping the, or propping up i would say as well as obviously uh soviet warsaw pact uh aid economic aid packages is keeping east germany going and so it happens on a sunday right yeah it's perfect time i mean what it's like uh didn't pearl harbour happen on sunday you always pick a really great time where you know christmas day would be there
他们连一根手指都不会动。他们本来可以这样做，但他们不会有后盾。因为关键是，在东德，你有超过30万红军部队。你有3000多辆俄国坦克、空军等等。这就是维持（或者我认为支撑，以及显然还有苏联华沙条约组织的援助、经济援助计划）东德运转的东西。所以它发生在周日，对吧？是的，完美的时间。我的意思是，这就像……珍珠港事件不是发生在周日吗？你总是挑一个非常棒的时间，你知道圣诞节那天会在那里
you go you know you know typical uh for for your listeners i'm sure if you guys have been there you go to berlin at the weekend everyone just leaves the city and tries to get to their their gardens or their allotments that they've got in the the various beautiful woods and and lakes that surround the city i mean it's fantastic but that was what was happening at the height of summer, August 13th. The great bulk of the city was just relaxing. The Allied garrisons themselves were relaxing. And no one, well, I say no one.
你去……你知道，对于你的听众来说，我确信如果你去过那里，你在周末去柏林，每个人都离开城市，试图去他们在环绕城市的各种美丽的树林和湖泊中拥有的花园或分配地。我的意思是，这太棒了，但这就是盛夏时节8月13日发生的事情。城市的大部分都在放松。盟军卫戍部队本身也在放松。没有人——好吧，我说没有人。
I mean, the Allies were expecting the East Germans and the Soviets to do something because the pressure had been building up all throughout 61 to that point where something had to be done to relieve this pressure. And that's when they struck. Operation Rose. And so just one quick question, which absolutely has always fascinated me. And it's something that people bring up all the time. If you throw a party and you have to lock your guests inside to stop them leaving, that may cause you to have questions about how good your party actually is, what a good host you are. Does it not occur to Walter Ulbricht and his
我的意思是，盟军原本预计东德人和苏联人会做点什么，因为整个61年到那个时候压力一直在积聚，必须做点什么来释放这种压力。就在那时他们出击了。玫瑰行动。所以只有一个简短的问题，这绝对一直让我着迷。这也是人们一直在提起的事情。如果你举办一个派对，你必须把客人锁在里面以阻止他们离开，这可能会让你对你的派对实际上有多好、你是一个多好的主人产生疑问？难道沃尔特·乌布利希和他的
colleagues that if they have to lock their citizens up behind a wall, do they never think about the quality of their regime and their offer, to use jargon you know do they never have a grain of self-doubt oh we've got to build this massive wall to keep everybody in because they're leaving well no because you're talking about uh complete 100 believers in the the socialist plan the utopia that they'd seen developing in in russia the soviet, since the end of the Russian Civil War by the mid-20s. I mean, these guys had been committed communists all throughout Hitler's period of power. Quite a few of them had actually fled to Russia and been housed in the Kremlin. I mean, Ulbricht is very famously one of the guys that's sitting in a trench with Khrushchev at Stalingrad in 1942-43,
同事们从来没有想过，如果他们必须把公民关在墙后面，他们难道从来没有反思过他们的政权和他们的供给的质量吗（用你们知道的行话来说）——难道他们从来没有哪怕一丝一毫的自我怀疑？哦，我们必须建造这堵巨大的墙把每个人都关在里面，因为他们要离开。哦，不，因为你在谈论……对社会主义计划的百分之百的信仰，他们在俄罗斯——自俄国内战结束到20年代中期以来——看到的正在发展的乌托邦。我的意思是，这些人在希特勒当政期间一直是坚定的共产主义者。相当多的人实际上逃到了俄罗斯，并被安置在克里姆林宫里。我的意思是，乌布利希非常著名地是1942-43年在斯大林格勒与赫鲁晓夫坐在战壕里的家伙之一，
giving propaganda speeches to the German troops that were surrounded in the city to try and break their morale. These guys had been honed to build the kind of country or you can call it dictatorship that the Kremlin wants. And also, I mean, the context also is denazification. So the wall is the, what is it, the great anti-fascist barrier. The anti-fascist barrier. And so people, presumably
向被围困在城市中的德国军队发表宣传演讲，试图瓦解他们的士气。这些人经过千锤百炼，旨在建立克里姆林宫想要的国家，或者你可以称之为独裁统治。而且，我的意思是，背景也是去纳粹化。所以墙是——什么？伟大的反法西斯防线。反法西斯防线。所以人们，据推测
people who are trying to escape to the West are cast as neo-Nazis, as fascists, as people seduced by the evil glamour of this kind of Hitlerian legacy. But it's harder to denounce them as that when, like we were saying earlier, a great deal, a great many of them are from the professional classes. And it wasn't just the odd one or two persons from your locale that would be going. Overnight, a whole factory could disappear.
试图逃往西方的人被塑造成新纳粹分子、法西斯分子、被这种希特勒式遗产的邪恶魅力所诱惑的人。但当就像我们刚才所说的那样，其中很大一部分人来自专业阶层时，就很难将他们妖魔化为那样了。而且不只是你当地偶尔的一两个人要走。一夜之间，整个工厂都可能消失。
Overnight, a whole doctor's surgery could disappear they would literally just put the shutters down put the lights out and go so you can't you can denounce them publicly but that to their to the locals who know them and everyone else who knows them they they know the truth they just haven't those that stay just didn't have the gumption to go the people at the top who are doing this and who presumably are not kind of full of self-doubt they they do see themselves as gauged in a kind of manichaean struggle but you know communism and fascism between light and and dark and so presumably in that light it makes you know you can justify it
一夜之间，整个医务所都可能消失，他们真的会把百叶窗拉上，熄灯然后离开，所以你可以在公开场合谴责他们，但对于了解他们的当地人和所有其他认识他们的人来说，他们知道真相，只是那些留下来的人没有离开的勇气。高层做这件事的人，据推测并不是那种充满自我怀疑的人，他们确实认为自己卷入了一种摩尼教式的斗争中（你知道的，共产主义和法西斯主义之间，光明与黑暗之间），所以在那种光芒下，它让你知道你可以为之辩护
because yeah well it's yeah i i yeah they they to them they were building the utopia and i again if you if you go to the various like i said amazing interactive museums they've built now over the last 10 15 years on a certain level the life that you would have in east germany especially by uh the 70s uh where there was more money more consumer goods that kind of thing. And like we said, you've got free healthcare, free education, job for life, et cetera. Guaranteed housing, basic, but guaranteed housing. To a lot of people, that's great. That's what they want. But I would argue to the generation that grew up just after the war, that was enough for them at the time. It's to the following generations, you and I, who are all now in our 50s, but back then in the 80s, we'd be teenagers in our 20s, we wanted more. Yeah. Okay. Well, we say the Berlin Wall has been built. I think we should have a commercial break now so that listeners can hear about all the consumer durables that
因为，是的，好吧，是的，我，我，我，对他们来说，他们在建设乌托邦，我再次说，如果你去各种——就像我说的——他们在过去10、15年里建立的令人惊叹的互动博物馆，在某种程度上，你在东德拥有的生活，特别是到70年代时，那里有更多的钱、更多的消费品之类的。就像我们说的，你有免费医疗、免费教育、终身工作等等。有保障的住房，基本的，但有保障的住房。对很多人来说，这很棒。这就是他们想要的。但我会认为，对于战后长大的那一代人来说，当时这就足够了。对于后来的几代人——你和我，我们现在都50多岁了，但在80年代那时候，我们是十几岁到20多岁——我们想要更多。好吧。嗯，我们说柏林墙已经建成了。我想我们现在应该插播一段广告，这样听众就可以听到西方资本主义社会所能提供的所有耐用消费品。然后当我们回来时，让我们看看当柏林被分裂时生活是什么样的，逃亡尝试等等，然后是它倒塌的过程。非常感谢。我们很快回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
Western capitalist society has to offer. And then when we come back, let's look at what it was like to live in Berlin when it was divided, escape attempts and so on, and then the process by which it fell. So thanks very much. We'll be back soon. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
西方资本主义社会所能提供的一切。稍后回来，我们将探讨柏林墙分裂时期的生活状况、逃亡尝试等等，以及最终倒塌的过程。非常感谢，我们马上回来。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,
我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝娱乐圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想无广告收听、获得加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in berlin a divided city the wall has just gone up in the summer of 1961 and uh our guest ian is talking us through life in berlin and what it was like to live in the divided city so in Ian, there are people who, I mean, their families are divided. They have girlfriends or boyfriends on the other side of the wall. I mean, so this just comes down overnight and your life is literally kind of ripped in two, I guess. Yes. I mean, you're looking at, so it's a city of over 3 million people.
访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。我们身处柏林，这是一个分裂的城市。柏林墙在1961年夏天刚刚修好。我们的嘉宾伊恩正在为我们讲述柏林的生活，以及在分裂城市中生活是什么体验。伊恩，有些人，我是说，他们的家庭破裂了。他们在墙的另一边有男或女朋友。我是说，这墙在一夜之间建起，你的生活简直可以说被撕成了两半。是的。我是说，这是一个拥有三百万以上人口的城市。
And as you were saying about how can you just split something like London or Paris, that's exactly what they did to Berlin. They did it really well, very efficiently, very quickly. So you've got overall, you've got 150 kilometers worth of barriers that went up straight away. And it wasn't a physical wall straight away. So that's what people need to realize. The East Germans and the Soviets were putting their toe in the water straight away with just cement posts and barbed wire. That was the very first, that was the first iteration of the barrier that went up because they had to see what the allies were going to do.
正如你刚才所说，怎么能把伦敦或帕里斯这样（的地方）分割开来，但这正是他们对柏林做的事。他们做得非常彻底、高效且迅速。因此总共修建了长达150公里的屏障。而且它并不是一开始就是一堵实体墙，这是人们需要意识到的。东德人和苏联人最初只是用水泥柱和带刺铁网在试探。那是第一代屏障，因为他们必须看看盟军会做出什么反应。
And as soon as they realized within 24 or 48 hours, well, actually they're not doing anything and we can handle the civilian uproar, but the allies themselves aren't trying to push through these barriers with tanks or armored cars. Let's crack on. And that was the next phase of Operation Rose. So you've got 192 streets overall cut off, 97 going out of Berlin into the East German hinterland, because like we were saying, it's 100 miles or so behind the West German barrier.
而一旦他们在24到48小时内意识到——好吧，实际上他们什么也没做，我们能应付平民的骚乱，但盟军本身并没有试图用坦克或装甲车冲破这些屏障——那就继续干吧。这就是“玫瑰行动”的下一阶段。因此总体来看，共有192条街道被切断，其中97条通往柏林以外的东德腹地，因为正如我们所说，它距离西德屏障有大约100英里远。
The overground train, the S-B-band the underground train system the u-band they've all been closed off the sewer systems are closed off so it was because people can escape through the sewer that's what they were doing so and it was very much again as i was talking to people that were there at the time and they were telling me their stories it was very much a cat and mouse so every time the mouse as in thee, is blocked on a certain way, so the underground system, the U-bands block, how am I going to get out? All right, I'll try the sewers. And it was successful for a few hours or maybe a day or so. And then the authorities found out and then they would block it. And you've got overall, across the city itself, where the main barriers were
地上铁路S-Bahn和地下铁路系统U-Bahn都被关闭了，下水道系统也被关闭了，因为人们可以通过下水道逃跑，他们当时就是这么做的。正如我和当时在场的人交流时他们所说的那样，这非常像猫捉老鼠的游戏。所以每当老鼠（指逃跑者）被某种方式封锁时，比如地下系统U-Bahn被封锁了，“我该怎么逃出去？好吧，我去试试下水道。”这种方法成功了几个小时或大概一天左右，然后当局发现了，就会将其封锁。总的来说，在整个城市中，当时正在修建主要屏障的地方，
being built at the time, you had 81 official crossing points that we're talking about all these tens of thousands of East Germans were able to cross over. They'd now been reduced to 10. And they were now being heavily reinforced. First of all, like I said, with cement posts and barbed wire, but within a few days, cement blocks, which is where we all see these famous scenes, they were going to be breeze blocks. Ironically, the material they used to build the first iteration of the berlin wall had originally been set aside to build this great new housing the workers were going to have in east berlin right that's why housing suffered all the way through the 60s until they managed to come up with more to build these houses because they'd use them on the berlin wall walls not houses but a quick question so not back in the early 1950s i think
原本有81个官方过境点，也就是我们所说的成千上万的东德人能够穿过的地方。现在这些过境点减少到了10个，并且正在受到重兵重重加固。首先，正如我所说，是用水泥柱和带刺铁网，但在几天之内，就换成了水泥砖，也就是我们所有人看到的那些著名场景中的煤渣砖。具有讽刺意味的是，用来建造第一代柏林墙的材料，原本是留着为东德工人们建造宏伟的新住房的。没错，这就是为什么住房问题在整个60年代一直很糟糕，直到他们设法生产出更多材料来盖这些房子——因为他们把材料用在柏林墙上了，修的是墙而不是房子。不过有个简单的问题，回溯到20世纪50年代初，我想是
1953 there had been a kind of an East German uprising. Yes. Bertolt Brecht made his famous remark about dissolving the people and getting new people. Get new people. Why is the no, why don't East Germans take, are they just so cowed and terrified that they don't take to the streets in 1961? Well, you've hit the nail on the head. So the East German government almost was toppled in 53, very quickly. It could have happened if the Russians hadn't come in with tanks. It would have happened.
1953年，曾经发生过一次东德起义。是的。贝托尔特·布莱希特（Bertolt Brecht）曾说过一句名言：“解散人民，另选人民。”换一拨人。为什么不，为什么东德人没有在1961年走上街头？他们是被吓破胆了吗？没错，你一针见血。东德政府在53年差点被推翻，非常快。如果苏联人没有带着坦克介入，这本可能会发生的，确实会发生。
But they learned their lesson. And so they'd spent a few weeks realising and briefing police, secret police, border guards and the regular East German army of how each unit was going to monitor and guard the borders as they were being closed. And specifically, they weren't looking west, really. A few of them were, but the majority of them weren't looking or pointing their guns westwards at West Berlin civilians or the Allies. They were looking eastwards towards their own people. The whole point was they had to suppress very quickly, suddenly, any kind of dissent that was going on, especially from their own uh their own troops border guards and police that might be thinking have second thoughts and think actually i don't want to be involved in building this wall i'm gonna i'm gonna either protest and help try and stop this because that's what had happened in 53 whole you know thousands of police and guard
但他们吸取了教训。因此他们花了几个星期的时间去意识到并向警察、秘密警察、边防卫兵和正规东德军队部署：在边境关闭时，每个单位将如何监视和守卫边境。具体来说，他们其实并不是在向西看。少数人是，但大多数人并没有将枪口指向西柏林平民或盟国。他们是在向东看，对着自己的人民。核心重点在于，他们必须非常迅速、突然地镇压任何可能出现的异议，尤其是来自他们自己的军队、边防卫兵和警察的异议——这些人可能会三思而后行，心想“其实我不想参与修墙，我要么去抗议，要么试图阻止这一切”，因为这就是53年发生过的事情，你知道，成千上万的警察和警卫
border guards had gone over to the protesters' side. And that's what they really were successful at stopping in 61. And from 61 to 89, how many escape attempts are made? How many succeed and how many people die? Well, it's roughly, the statistics say it's over 10,000 escapes were made. And that's not just through the Berlin Wall itself, but that's obviously through the intra-German border, which is far harder to get through, I would say, especially in the 60s. Because like I was saying, it was only by the mid to late 70s and then going into the 80s that I've
边防卫兵倒向了抗议者一边。而这正是他们在1961年成功制止的事情。从1961年到1989年，发生了多少次逃跑尝试？有多少成功了，有多少人死亡？嗯，大致统计显示，有超过10,000次逃跑尝试。这不仅通过柏林墙本身，显然还通过两德边界，我要说，这个边界要难得多，尤其是在60年代。因为正如我所说，直到70年代中期到后期以及80年代，我才
got a really lovely diagram of it in the book. It shows you how impossibly difficult it would have been to get across what was then called the death strip to get from East to West Berlin. I mean, it was practically impossible to actually get across on foot. You'd be caught or killed. Whereas the inter-German border was slightly a little bit easier and less lethal. So it was about 10,000, and they reckon it was anywhere between 3,000 to 5,000 were successful.
在书里放了一张非常精美的图表。它向你展示了要穿过当时被称为“死亡地带”的地方是从东柏林到西柏林是多么不可能的困难。我的意思是，实际上根本不可能步行穿过。你会被抓住或打死。相比之下，两德边界要稍微容易一些，致命性也小一些。所以大约有10,000次，他们估计成功率在3,000到5,000人之间。
But again, if you look at the statistics, it's in the early days. So when you've got the first iteration of the war, the first iteration of the death strip, it's not as sophisticated or as highly monitored as it was by the 80s to where it's practically impossible. So a lot more people took their chance of trying to escape in the 60s. And that leads me to tell you that there's over about 200 deaths altogether, eight of whom were East German border guards caught in crossfire when there was gun battles exchanged with people escaping. But the majority of the deaths were in the 60s, because that's when it was seen as easier to try your luck. Whereas by the 70s, you wouldn't do it. And that's why you famously, by the 70s you wouldn't do it and that's why you famously by
但话说回来，如果你看统计数据，这发生在早期。所以当柏林墙的第一代、死亡地带的第一代出现时，它不像80年代那样先进或监控严密，80年代时那里几乎是不可能通过的。因此，在60年代有更多的人冒险尝试逃跑。这促使我告诉你们，总共发生了大约200多起死亡事件，其中8人是在与逃跑者交火中被交叉火力击中的东德边防卫兵。但大多数死亡事件发生在60年代，因为当时人们觉得碰碰运气比较容易。相比之下，到了70年代，你不会这么做了。这就是为什么众所周知，到了70年代你不会这么做，这就是为什么众所周知，到了
the 70s and 80s you got people trying to tunnel underneath because that was the the safest option of uh not being discovered and obviously getting as many people out as possible and some of the people who die are children right or teenagers at least yeah yeah i mean there's uh there's one tragic case of a mother uh was escaping uh in the car going through the checkpoint and her baby was starting to cry. And so she smothered the baby in obviously trying to quieten her down. And by the time they got through the checkpoint, she's actually suffocated. So tragic, tragic stories like that. But I mean, the first death was literally two weeks after the first of the
70和80年代，人们开始尝试在地下挖地道，因为这是不被发现且显然能尽可能多地把人救出来的最安全选择。而且死者中有些是儿童，对吧？至少是青少年。对，对，我是说，有一个悲惨的案例：一位母亲在驾车通过检查站时试图逃跑，她的婴儿开始哭泣。于是她捂住婴儿的口鼻，显然是想让她安静下来。等他们通过检查站时，孩子实际上已经窒息身亡了。像这样悲惨、悲惨的故事还有很多。但我是说，第一起死亡事件发生在柏林墙第一段于8月13日修建后的仅仅两周内。
wall had gone up in August the 13th. So 24th of August was the first death by shooting. And that's when obviously both sides knew that, wow, these guys are for real. They are really going to kill their own citizens who are trying to escape. And that was a tailor called Gunther Lithgen, who, a bit of a Del boy, for those who know Only Fu know only fuels and horses, he was a tailor, but he did job, he lived in the East, but he earned his living in the West. And obviously the ratio, the disparity between Western currency, which would buy you a hell of a lot more if you lived in the East, which is what a lot of hundreds of thousands of Berliners were doing at the time. And he just was in the wrong place at the wrong time. And he was actually moving to West Berlin when they closed the war.
因此，8月24日发生了第一起枪击致死事件。正是在那时，双方显然都意识到，哇，这些家伙是玩真的。他们真的会枪杀试图逃跑的自己国家的公民。那是一个名叫冈瑟·利特根（Gunther Lithgen）的裁缝，他有点像《只有傻瓜和马》（Only Fools and Horses）里的“骗子”（Del Boy），他是个裁缝，但他做零工，住在东柏林，却在西柏林谋生。显然，西方货币的比率和差距很大，如果你住在东柏林，这笔钱能买到多得多的东西，这也是当时成千上万柏林人正在做的事情。而他只是在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点。当他们封锁柏林墙时，他正准备搬到西柏林去。
He just happened to be on the Eastern side because he'd gone to collect things. And he spent the next two weeks going up and down the border, trying to figure out where he could try his luck and escape. Realized, right, I'm going to try here. Tried to swim across one of the canals that were connected, that flow into the Spray River. And they fired a few warning shots at him, and then he was hit three times, and he died on the western side.
他刚好因为去取东西而留在了东侧。他在接下来的两周里沿着边境上下奔波，试图找出自己能去哪里碰运气并逃跑。他意识到，好，我要在这里尝试。他试图游过一条与施普雷河相连、流入施普雷河的运河。他们向他开了几声警告枪，然后他中了三枪，死在了西侧。
And obviously, as Tom was saying, he was then denounced in the Eastern press as a fascist agitator that tried his luck to flee to the west and had been stopped. And he was the first death. And like I said, that was definitely a red flag that the regime was flying to the population to say, okay, you can try it, but this is what's going to happen to you. And the majority of the deaths were in the 60s.
显然，正如汤姆所说，他随后在东方媒体上被谴责为一个法西斯煽动者，试图侥幸逃往西方并被制止。他是第一个死者。正如我所说，这绝对是政权向民众发出的红色信号，意思是：“好吧，你们可以尝试，但这就是你们将要遭遇的下场。”而且大多数死亡都发生在60年代。
Right. So you've said that there were 10 crossing points in the war. And the most famous one is the one that you've given as the title to your book checkpoint charlie yeah um and i suppose check the notoriety of checkpoint charlie is that it's seen as the flash point that makes berlin the most dangerous place in the world for much of the of the cold war that's the reputation that it has. How deserved is that, do you think? How dangerous is the Berlin Wall as a possible trigger for the Cold War becoming hotter? Well, it's much like where we've got today
没错。所以你提到过，柏林墙上有10个过境点。其中最著名的一个就是你用作书名的查理检查站（Checkpoint Charlie）。对。而且我想查理检查站的恶名在于，它被视为使柏林在冷战大部分时间里成为世界上最危险地方的爆发点。这就是它的声誉。你认为这种名声实至名归吗？作为冷战可能变得更加炽热的导火索，柏林墙究竟有多危险？嗯，这很像我们今天所看到的
with the demarcation line between North and South Korea. So you've got seriously heavily armed forces just pointing their guns at each other in a kind of pseudo kind of almost peace treaties going on. It's the same with Checkpoint Charlie and the Berlin Wall itself in Berlin. It was the one place where allied, predominantly American, but allied soldiers,
朝鲜和韩国之间的分界线。因此，你有一支装备精重的武装部队，在某种伪和平条约的表象下，彼此互相对准枪口。查理检查站和柏林柏林墙本身也是如此。这是盟军士兵——主要是美国士兵，但也有盟军士兵——的唯一聚集地，
usually the elite units that were stationed there. And it was a garrison of about 10,000 altogether, French, German, sorry, French, American and British, faced off with Soviet units as well. And famously, Checkpoint Charlie was given the code name straight after the Berlin Wall had gone up because the Allies had to have the three points of contact. You've got the East-West German checkpoint crossing that would get you access through that 100 miles of Soviet territory. That was Checkpoint Alpha. That would then get you to Checkpoint Bravo, which was giving you entrance into the Allied sectors. And then the next sector, phonetically, would be Checkpoint Charlie. And that's why it was given that. And that was still the one crossing point that Allied military
通常是驻扎在那里的精锐部队。那里总共驻扎了大约10,000人的 garrison（驻军），包括法国、德国，抱歉，法国、美国和英国军队，与苏联部队对峙。众所周知，查理检查站是在柏林墙刚刚建好后被赋予代号的，因为盟军必须拥有三个接触点。你拥有东西德检查站过境点，它能让你通过苏联领土的那100英里。那是Alpha检查站。然后它会带你到Bravo检查站，这让你能够进入盟军控制区。接着下一个区，按语音拼写（音标首字母），就会是查理检查站（Charlie）。这就是它得名的原因。那仍然是盟军军事人员唯一可以
and Allied diplomatic international staff were expected and allowed to cross into the Soviet zone. Because what you've got to remember is, yes, they built the border. Yes, they were entombing their own East German citizens inside their own country, their own city. But they still had to abide by the international agreements that had been signed off at Potsdam. Why? Why did they have to? Because that was their way of making sure that Kennedy at the time, JFK, who was obviously president of the United States and Macmillan in the UK, wouldn't interfere with the first iteration of the war. As long as the allies could see that they're not encroaching on our territory,
以及盟军外交国际工作人员被期望和允许跨入苏联控制区的过境点。因为你必须记住的是，是的，他们修建了边境。是的，他们将自己的东德公民埋葬在自己的国家、自己的城市里。但他们仍然必须遵守在波茨坦签署的国际协议。为什么？为什么他们必须遵守？因为那是他们确保当时担任美国总统的肯尼迪（JFK）和英国首相麦克米伦不会干涉第一代柏林墙的建造的方式。只要盟军能看到他们没有侵犯我们的领土，
our sectors, and they're still allowing us, our troops, our allied diplomatic personnel to have their usual free entry into the Soviet zone to travel around as they please. Those rules hadn't been broken. But to everyone else, obviously, who were trying to escape, that was the new world they were living in. Talking about the border guards and stuff, you have a lovely line in your book that I thought was fascinating. It was about the, you say, close relationships develop between Russian and British commanders
我们的控制区，并且他们仍然允许我们的军队、盟军外交人员照常自由进入苏联控制区以随心所欲地四处旅行。这些规则就没有被打破。但对于其他所有人来说，显然，那些试图逃跑的人，这就是他们生活的新世界。谈到边境卫兵之类的事情，你的书里有一句非常精彩的话，我觉得很迷人。它是关于，你说，俄罗斯和英国指挥官之间发展出了密切的关系，
rooted in mutual respect and the copious consumption of whiskey. Whiskey, vodka. So they are facing off. They are both armed. There is this sense of paranoia and mutual suspicion. But they develop a kind of, as the war becomes something you take for granted they basically end up they're not they're never friends obviously but they end up kind of getting
这种关系植根于相互尊重以及大量消耗威士忌。威士忌，伏特加。所以他们针锋相对。他们都武装起来了。有一种偏执和相互猜疑的感觉。但他们发展出了一种，随着柏林墙变成一种你习以为常的东西，他们基本上最终，他们当然永远不会成为朋友，但他们最终还是能够
along is that right yeah they they do what i found funny was uh all the allied uh soldiers and diplomats i talked to had huge respect for the sovi not much respect for the East Germans, especially on the military intelligence side, which is what you're referring to, Dominic. So we had the military intelligence units that all sides had in the city that were allowed technically to check each other out. Because again, that was one of the unwritten rules that a lot of the the civilian populations in in the respective cold war countries never knew the soviets the americans the french and the british all allowed uh intelligence units to go along agreed lines of travel into in and out of uh uh the eastern sector in the western sector and so this is what this is this is what
相处融洽，是这样吗？是的，他们确实如此。我觉得有趣的是，我交谈过的所有盟军士兵和外交官对苏联人都有着极大的尊重，但对东德人则没有多少尊重，特别是在军事情报方面，多米尼克，也就是你所指的那方面。所以我们有各方在城市中拥有的军事情报单位，按技术上说是被允许互相监视的。因为这也是那些未成文的规则之一，冷战相关国家各自的许多平民永远不会知道：苏联人、美国人、法国人和英国人都允许情报人员沿着商定的旅行路线进出东方控制区和西方控制区，所以这就是
makes it the world capital of espionage absolutely yeah all that reputation that yeah like harry and everything that it is justified is it yeah because i think it was it was a very good way of both sides uh trusting each other i use that very delicately that way that uh there weren't any surprises in terms of uh troops that might be stationed in that particular area or weaponry technology that was being used. Both sides were giving each other a small amount of leeway to check each other out to make sure that there was some kind of tacit agreement or a level of trust between the two. And that gets back to the point of where they would have regular
使这里成为世界间谍之都的原因。绝对是的。所有那种声誉，是的，就像哈利波特（注：原文口误，指间谍小说）和所有这些，都是实至名归的，是吗？是的，因为我认为这是一种非常好的方式，让双方能够彼此信任——我非常谨慎地使用这个词——也就是说，在可能驻扎在特定区域的军队或正在使用的武器技术方面，没有任何意外。双方都给对方留出了一小部分余地去互相检查，以确保两者之间存在某种默契或信任水平。这就回到了他们会定期
get-togethers. And obviously they were official get-togethers, but a lot of the time they ended up swapping caps with each other, giving each other badges, and obviously getting drunk on vodka and whiskey. And yeah, there was a lot of respect, but on the East German side, no, because the Allies made a point of making sure that the East Germans realized that you're not a sovereign country. We don't recognize what you've done to the city. We don't recognize what you've done to the city. We don't recognize what you're doing to your own citizenship.
聚会的那个点。显然那是官方聚会，但很多时候他们最终会互相交换帽子、赠送徽章，当然还有喝伏特加和威士忌喝得酩酊大醉。是的，有很多尊重，但在东德这一边，没有，因为盟军特意确保东德人意识到：你不是一个主权国家。我们不承认你对这座城市做过的事。我们不承认你对这座城市做过的事。我们不承认你对你自己的公民做过的事。
And that gets down, if you drill down to what Checkpoint Charlie actually looked like, it was just a small wooden hut, very insignificant. It meant a lot, but it was just very insignificant. Where if you go 500 yards from that checkpoint to the East German checkpoint, by 1989, huge complex. They spent millions and millions and millions of pounds on, dollars worth, to make it as sophisticated as possible to make sure that when you came through, like going through Heathrow Terminal 5, you're going through layer after layer of checks and passport control and, you know, they had cameras everywhere. And that was them, again, puffing their chests out saying you are entering our sovereign nation and look how powerful and strong we are
如果深入探究查理检查站实际的样子，它只是一个非常不起眼的小木屋。它意义重大，但本身非常不起眼。如果你从那个检查站走500码到东德检查站，到了1989年，那是一个巨大的综合体。他们花了几百万、几百万、几百万英镑、美元，使其尽可能先进，以确保当你穿过时，就像通过希思罗机场5号航站楼一样，你要经过一层又一层的检查、护照控制，而且到处都是摄像头。这又是他们在挺起胸膛说：你正在进入我们的主权国家，看看我们有多强大
and the the the the most notorious flashpoint is is when an american diplomat is going to the opera yes in east berlin yeah and is isn't it what what kind of triggers the it ends up with tanks facing each other isn't isn't that because it's an East German guard asking for his credentials rather than a Soviet one? Yeah, but that had been building for a couple of months. So August, you've got the war going up. This happened in October. So by October, Kennedy has obviously reinforced the Allied garrison. He sent a battle group right up the autobahn, unchallenged,
而最臭名昭著的爆发点是，一名美国外交官要去东柏林听歌剧，对吧？是的。难道不是吗？是什么引发了——最终导致了坦克互相面对面？难道不是因为一个东德卫兵要求查看他的证件，而不是苏联卫兵吗？是的，但那已经酝酿了好几个月了。所以八月份柏林墙建起来。这发生在十月。因此到了十月，肯尼迪显然增援了盟军驻军。他派了一个战斗群沿著高速公路一直开过去，没有遇到任何阻拦。
a couple of thousand guys. He sent his vice president, Johnson, to go and bolster the morale of the Berliners who felt they were being abandoned by the Allies. But he also sent, as his kind of man on the ground, he didn't have a position in the chain of command, General Lucius Clay, who had been the very first Allied Commandant of Berlin post Second World War Berlin in 1945,
几千名士兵。他派了副总统约翰逊去鼓舞柏林人的士气，因为柏林人觉得他们被盟友抛弃了。但他也派出了卢修斯·克莱将军作为他在当地的代表——虽然克莱在指挥链中没有正式职位，但他曾是1945年二战后柏林的第一任盟军司令，
and was also seen as the architect of the very successful Berlin Airlift. So to Berliners, West Berliners, he was a hero. He still is a hero if you go over there today. One of the main thoroughfares in in berlin's clay alley uh he was sent over and he was the instigator of this standoff in october 61 where one of the diplomats alan leiter was taking his wife like i was saying free access uh unmolested into east germany uh sorry into east berlin because that's where all the main theatres and operas were still operating.
也被视为非常成功的柏林空运的策划者。因此，对柏林人、西柏林人来说，他是个英雄。如果你今天去那里，他依然是个英雄。柏林的一条主要干道叫克莱小巷。他被派往那里，是1961年10月这场对峙的煽动者。当时，外交官之一阿伦·莱特正带着他的妻子，就像我刚才说的，享受自由出入、畅通无阻地前往东德——抱歉，是东营柏林，因为那里所有的主要剧院和歌剧院仍在营业。
You could have an amazing lavish night out that would cost you peanuts because of the ratio in discrepancy of currency. But instead of allowed to be driven through unmolested without his papers being checked because he had his diplomatic plates on, as you said, the East German officer insisted. He refused. And he was just stuck there with his wife, Dorothy, in the Volkswagen until Clay heard on the as you said the east german officer insisted he refused and he was just stuck there with his wife dorothy in the volkswagen until clay heard on the phone and he was rubbing his hands with glee thinking this is the chance i've been waiting for and he sent a platoon of uh fixed bayonets uh us mps in their jeeps to go through not only surround the volkswagen and intimidate these german guards but then to say, and just carry on. And they drove them.
由于汇率差异悬殊，你可以度过一个极其奢华的夜晚，而花费却微乎其微。但是，正如你所说，由于他挂着外交车牌，本可以不受阻挠地开车通过、无需检查证件，但东德官员却坚持要查。他拒绝了。他和妻子多萝西就被困在甲壳虫汽车里，直到克莱在电话里听到这件事。正如你所说，东德官员坚持检查，他拒绝了，他和妻子多萝西就被困在甲壳虫汽车里，直到克莱在电话里听到这件事，他搓着双手幸灾乐祸地想，这是他一直在等待的机会，于是他派了一个排的、上了刺刀的美军宪兵开着吉普车赶来，不仅包围了甲壳虫汽车并恐吓这些东德警卫，还下令让他们继续前进。于是他们开车送了他们。
They didn't drive them to the theatre. He made a point of driving them all the way around the inner part of the city as a kind of show of defiance to say, you're not going to stop us. And then this happened two, three nights in a row. And by that time, Clay had thought, right, they're still not backing down. I'm going to have to up the ante. And this is all without the knowledge of Kennedy and the White House, what was going on. They just trusted him to do this because obviously this is well before the communications we have today.
他们并不是开车送他们去剧院。他特意开车带着他们绕着城市内城转了一圈，作为一种挑衅的姿态，意思是：你们阻拦不了我们。然后这种情况连续发生了两三晚。到了这个时候，克莱心想，好吧，他们还是不肯退缩。我得把赌注加码。而这一切都是在肯尼迪和白宫不知情的情况下发生的。他们只是信任他会这么做，因为这显然远早于我们今天拥有的通讯水平。
And that's where tanks started to go to DEFCON 3, then to launches of bombers, etc., etc. And that's when obviously a panic JFK in the White House got involved. And that's where both sides managed to calm it down, because obviously the Russians were thinking, well, if you're going to bring tanks to the party, so are we. But obviously, the Russians could bring hundreds of tanks. And the Allies only had what they were allowed to have in the garrison in Berlin, which was a dozen at best. Like I said, there was a garrison of 10,000 troops altogether. All three countries, three sectors had a squadron of tanks and armored cars. They would have been squashed within hours. So there was not only Russian tanks that you'll
正是在那时，坦克开始进入 DEFCON 3 级战备，接着是轰炸机起飞等等。也就是在那时，白宫的肯尼迪陷入了恐慌并介入了。双方正是在那时设法缓和了局势，因为俄罗斯人显然在想，好吧，如果你们要把坦克开进场，我们也会。但显然，俄罗斯人可以调集数百辆坦克。而盟军只能拥有他们在柏林卫戍部队中被允许拥有的数量，最多也就是十多辆。就像我说的，总共只有一万人的卫戍部队。所有三个国家、三个防区各有一个中队坦克和装甲车。几个小时内他们就会被压碎。所以不仅有俄罗斯坦克，你还会在
see in the very famous photos at the checkpoint facing off against American tanks, there's dozens of them parked in the streets. So the Americans knew that they stood no chance. And that's why it was talked down. And very quickly afterwards, once it had calmed down, that's when Kennedy ordered Clay home. Not in disgrace, but he was ordered quietly home. Yeah, calm down. Let's get on from getting on yeah we don't actually have tons of time left actually this this has really flown by and we've completely failed to ask any of our audiences questions that we sort of maliciously solicited and then have you got them there because i haven't there was a question about um well actually i know what i want to ask. I'm going to ask what I want, Tom. Go on, cut it down.
检查站看到那些非常著名的照片，里面与美国坦克对峙的街上停着几十辆坦克。所以美国人知道他们毫无胜算。这就是为什么局势最终得以缓和的原因。在这之后不久，局势平静下来后，肯尼迪便下令召回克莱。不是带着耻辱离开，而是被悄悄召回。对，冷静下来。让我们继续往前看。是的，我们其实没有太多时间了，时间真的过得飞快，我们完全忘了问那些我们恶意征集来的观众的问题。你把问题准备好了吗？我没有。有一个关于——其实我知道我想问什么。我要问我想问的，汤姆。说吧，长话短说。
So tons of people said, did David Hasselhoff bring down the Bowie War? That's the question I wanted to ask. Is that the question? I knew you were going to ask that question. I was trying to find it on Twitter. So lots of people asked this question about David Hasselhoff, David Bowie, of course, Bruce Springsteen. I think you talk about Bruce Springsteen, don't you, in your book? Yeah, yeah.
所以很多人说，大卫·哈塞尔霍夫推倒了柏林墙吗？这就是我想问的问题。是这个问题吗？我就知道你会问这个问题。我刚才一直在推特上找它。所以很多人问了关于大卫·哈塞尔霍夫、大卫·鲍伊，当然还有布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的问题。我想你在书里也谈到了布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀，对吧？是的，是的。
So this becomes a kind of different kind of confrontation that the Allies, the West, will have these gigs or have these events. I mean, Ronald Reagan shouting, you know, Mr. Gorbachev, tear down this wall. And they do this deliberately, do they? And the musicians in particular, they're kind of rock stars. They are party to it. They know what they're getting into. They're perfectly happy to be co-opted as kind of cold. Yeah.
所以这变成了一种不同类型的对抗，盟友、西方会举办这些音乐会或活动。我的意思是，罗纳德·里根大喊：“里根总统，推倒这堵墙。”他们是故意这样做的吗？尤其是音乐家们，他们算是一种摇滚明星。他们参与其中。他们知道自己卷入了什么。他们非常乐意被体制化，作为某种冷战工具。是的。
I mean, they, uh, there's lots of stars had, uh, major, major concerts in West Berlin. So you're talking about David Bowie.
我的意思是，他们，呃，有很多明星在西柏林举办过大型、大型的演唱会。所以你在说大卫·鲍伊。
There was also Michael Jackson, uh, Brian Adams, uh, in the eighties. Uh, and they caused a lot of disruption on the Eastern side because you, like I was saying,
80年代还有迈克尔·杰克逊、布赖恩·亚当斯。他们在东部引起了很大的骚乱，因为正如我所说，
you've now got your generate your second generation of young East Germans in their twenties, the teenagers in their twenties thinking, wow, we want this world because they can, they can, they can, they're getting all this music on their,
你现在有了第二代年轻的东德人，二十多岁的年轻人，二十多岁的青少年心想，哇，我们想要这个世界，因为他们可以，他们可以，他们可以，他们通过他们的，
their legal radio sets. And so they could go right up to the border within reason. And cause you're obviously going to hear it in the city. You can hear this music going on and the likes of Bowie and Michael Jackson, they were very clever and they had their gigs and they had their speakers, some of which turned to the East to make sure the population could hear it.
合法的收音机听到所有这些音乐。因此，在情理之中，他们可以一直走到边境。因为你显然能在城里听到。你能听到音乐声不断传出，像鲍伊和迈克尔·杰克逊这样的人非常聪明，他们举办演唱会时带着扬声器，其中一些朝向东方，以确保民众能够听到。
But this had caused civil unrest and lots of people arrested and imprisoned. So by the time I talk about, I talked about Bruce Springsteen because that was a seminal moment in 88 where he didn't give his concert in West Berlin. He gave his concert in East Berlin. He was invited by the East German government because by then,
但这引发了内乱，许多人被捕入狱。所以当我谈到布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀时，那是因为1988年是一个具有开创性的时刻，他没有在西柏林举办演唱会，而是在东柏林举办了演唱会。他是由东德政府邀请的，因为到那时，
88, you've got a younger generation. They're still fanatics, but they're in government, and they're telling the older leadership hanging on to power, we have to give some kind of panacea to the younger generation, or this is just going to roll on and on. We've got to show them that we're developing, we're evolving. And that's why Springsteen was allowed to perform there. And he was on his tour in Europe anyway, so it fitted. But what they weren't expecting, they thought they'd get 70,000 to 80,000, 90,000 people that were specially invited. So I've got one of the tickets,
在88年，你拥有了年轻一代。他们仍然是狂热分子，但他们已经进入了政府，他们对死拽着权力不放的老一代领导人说，我们必须给年轻一代一些灵丹妙药，否则这种情况将没完没了地持续下去。我们必须向他们展示我们在发展，我们在演变。这就是斯普林斯汀被允许在那里演出的原因。无论如何，他当时正在欧洲巡演，所以时间上很合适。但他们没有料到的是，他们以为会来7万到8万、9万名特邀观众——我有一张票，
they're all printed. But people will say it's between 200 and 250,000 people flocked to see him. And as we all know, he's a very intelligent man. He's politically motivated as well to a degree. He could see what was going on in front of him. And that's why I wouldn't argue he politicized the event, but he definitely gave a very heartfelt speech about freedom. And then obviously he sang his Bob Dylan song, Chimes of Freedom. And that had a major, major effect because that kind of event and the ripples it caused to that generation of East Germans couldn't keep a lid on that. That was just another chip in the wall of what had been going on throughout the 80s
都是印好的。但人们说有20万到25万蜂拥而至来看他。众所周知，他是一个非常聪明的人。在某种程度上，他也有政治动机。他能看到眼前发生的事情。这就是为什么我认为他并没有将活动政治化，但他确实发表了一番非常真挚的关于自由的演讲。然后显而易见，他唱了鲍勃·迪伦的歌《自由的钟声》。这产生了重大、重大的影响，因为这种活动以及它对那一代东德人造成的涟漪效应是无法掩盖的。这只是80年代以来不断发生的推翻柏林墙的又一块敲门砖
anyway. And so then going into 89, what is the process by which the wall ends up falling? So from, say, 83 all the way up to 89, the peace movement had been growing in East Germany and that provided a protective
无论如何。因此，进入89年，柏林墙最终倒塌的过程是怎样的？所以从83年一直到89年，和平运动在东德不断壮大，这为成千上万、甚至数以十万计的人抗议他们想抗议的任何事情提供了一个保护
umbrella for thousands and hundreds of thousands of people to protest about whatever they wanted to protest for. But it was under the guise of they were, it was in line with the church, which had been sanctioned and allowed in the 80s by the government. Because again, it was one of their ways of trying to keep the populace in check. But by 89, the peace movement had just mushroomed exploded so you've got major major uh marches peaceful marches but protest marches nonetheless that were happening in the major cities outside of uh berlin in east germany so leipzig and dresden and the key thing was they
伞。但它是以教堂的名义进行的，教堂在80年代得到了政府的认可和允许。因为同样地，这是他们试图控制民众的方法之一。但到了89年，和平运动已经如雨后春笋般爆发了。所以你有了重大、重大的游行——和平游行，但尽管如此仍是抗议游行——在东德柏林以外的主要城市发生，比如莱比锡和德累斯顿。关键在于他们
weren't brutally suppressed they weren't stopped They were allowed to march hundreds of thousands of people. So again, that kind of imagery is making its way around the country of East Germany, but obviously into West Germany, into the Allies as well. And once you've taken that momentous step, it's then there's just a natural progress. And the east german government with the younger generation that was about to take over in a bloodless coup and got rid of eric honica who'd been who'd been actually the the architect of the berlin wall had built it and then governed from 1970 all the way through to 89 he was very very much ardent communist uh he'd been ousted in in october but uh you get agon krenz don't you agon krenz yeah and
没有遭到残酷镇压，也没有被制止。数十万人被允许游行。所以同样的，这种形象在东德全国传播开来，当然也传到了西德和盟友那里。一旦你迈出了这具有重大意义的一步，接下来的进展就是自然而然的了。东德政府中即将通过一场不流血政变接权、赶走了埃里希·昂纳克的年轻一代——昂纳克实际上是柏林墙的策划者，他修建了柏林墙，并从1970年一直统治到89年，他是一个非常、非常坚定的共产主义者，他在10月份被赶下台——但你迎来了埃贡·克伦茨，对吧？埃贡·克伦茨，是的，还有
key thing agon krenz had seen what the chinese had done in chenamon square that year where there'd been a very brutal bloody crackdown of civilian protests thousands killed he didn't what he didn't want as he said he didn't want a chinese solution to what was going on in his own country and that's why there was definitely a kind of, let's back off and give them what they want and we'll try to manage this. And it was the process of trying to manage this, but making sure that the one party state was still intact that led to the terrible press conference about announcing... Yeah, it's all a mistake, isn't it? Isn't it all a mistake and it all goes wrong? I found the actual annotated briefing notes that were given to Schabowski, the press secretary, by Egon Krenz.
关键一点是，埃贡·克伦茨看到了中国人在那年的天安门广场上所做的事情，那里对平民抗议进行了非常残酷、血腥的镇压，数千人丧生。他不想要，正如他所说，他不想要用“中国方案”来解决自己国家正在发生的事情。这就是为什么肯定有一种态度是：我们退后一步，给他们想要的，我们来试着控制局面。正是这种试图控制局面的过程，同时确保一党制仍然完好无损，导致了那场糟糕的新闻发布会，宣布……是的，这一切都是个错误，对吧？这一切难道不是个错误，然后全搞砸了吗？我找到了给新闻秘书沙博斯基的实际带批注简报，那是埃贡·克伦茨给他的。
And he scribbled all over it. And he just hadn't bothered reading it properly because he was tired. He'd been involved in all the press briefings for weeks to the Western allies and to his own countrymen about what was going to be delivered to them to solve this problem. He'd been given a week's leave because he was exhausted, came back, and his first job was to give this press conference on the 9th of November. And he just didn't read the brief properly, wasn't over the brief. And instead of saying the plans that they were going to do further down the line over the coming months of announcing how they would give their countrymen free movement of travel because that's really what these germans wanted above all else that's why they were trying to press to go out of austria and hungary and that kind of places uh he announced oh it happens immediately yeah he had
他在上面乱涂乱画。而且他因为太累了，根本没有好好看。他已经连续几个星期向西方盟友和同胞进行各种简报，说明将如何解决这个问题。他因为筋疲力尽而被准假一周，回来后，他的第一项工作就是在11月9日主持这场新闻发布会。他只是没有好好阅读简报，对简报内容不熟。他本该在未来几个月里逐步公布那些旨在让同胞享有自由旅行权利的计划——因为这确实是东德人最想要的东西，这也是他们试图通过奥地利和匈牙利等地出境的原因——但他却宣布：“哦，这立即生效！”是的，他有
one job one journey i would imagine i would imagine that's what egon said to him you had one job to do and uh and so that goes out and then everyone starts piling over well they do well they no no they go through the entry points yeah they pile down to the checkpoints and it's almost i mean it's a horrible thing to say but it's almost like a hillsborough moment you could say you've got these tens of thousands of people that have gone to all these you know dozen checkpoints along the border and it's just creating a crush and to the the commanders on the ground they haven't been given any instructions their urgent phone calls that they were giving every five minutes aren't answered by their next chain of command and as we know it's command economy it's
一个任务，一次旅行，我猜，我想埃贡就是这么对他说：“你只有一个任务要做，”然后消息传出去了，接着每个人都开始蜂拥而至——好吧，他们去往——不，不，他们通过入境点——是的，他们涌向检查站。这几乎可以说是——这是一个很难听的说法，但它几乎就像希尔斯堡惨案时刻，你可以这么说。你有成千上万的人去了所有这些，你知道的，边境沿线的十几个检查站，这造成了极大的拥挤。现场的指挥官们没有得到任何指令，他们每五分钟打一次的紧急电话也没有得到上级指挥链的回答。正如我们所知，这是命令经济，它也是
command policing structure as well they don't know what to do and they're thinking well i'm not going to be the guy responsible to to open fire on my own people to clear this look at them how can i get rid of them all so they had to open the gates and own people to clear this. Look at them. How can I get rid of them all? So they had to open the gates. And obviously the Allies are watching. So it's the guards who make the decision. So it's not going up to Krentz or Gorbachev or anybody else. No, no.
命令警务结构，他们不知道该怎么做，他们心想，我可不想成为那个为了疏散人群而向自己同胞开枪的人，看看他们，我怎么才能把他们全都弄走？所以他们不得不打开大门，向自己同胞开枪来疏散。看看他们。我怎么才能把他们全都弄走？所以他们不得不打开大门。显然盟友们在看着。所以是警卫们做出了决定。这不是上报给克伦茨、戈尔巴乔夫或其他任何人。不，不。
The commanders on the ground gave the key decision to open the gates. But what was discussed as this was going on at the very highest level were, as we saw in China, you had the hardliners in the government and in the military and in the Stasi saying, we have to crack down. We have units around the city, motorized elite units we can bring in and we can put this to bed within 24 hours. It's going to cost a lot of blood, but we can do it.
现场的指挥官们做出了打开大门的关键决定。但当时在最高层讨论这件事时，正如我们在中国看到的那样，政府、军队和史塔西内部的强硬派说：“我们必须镇压。我们在城市周围有部队，我们可以调来精锐摩托化部队，在24小时内平息此事。这会付出很多鲜血的代价，但我们能做到。”
Where you've got Krenzer, fair play to him, and his wing of the party saying, well, no, this can't happen. We can't do that. We can't have a Chinese solution in a country like ours. How would it look? And we've spent months trying to soften our way to where we need to be. And that's the decision to take. So again, I've interviewed people in the book that, you know,
而克伦茨——说句公道话——以及他那派的人说：“不，这不能发生。我们不能那样做。我们不能在我们这样的国家采用中国方案。这看起来会怎么样？我们花了几个月的时间，试图用温和的方式达到我们需要的目标。”所以这是做出的决定。同样地，我在书中采访过一些人，你知道的，
there's one guy who was at the officer training camp that was on the East German Czech border. They'd been having emergency riot control training for a week, thinking they were going to be bussed into the city to quell it. And obviously they were then to be bussed into the city to quell it. And obviously, they were then told to stand down. So there were lots of, I'm sure it will come out eventually. But there were lots of very high strategic conversations going on. And as we said, right at the beginning, that the Russians propped them up from when they started in,
有一个人在东德和捷克边境的军官训练营。他们进行了为期一周的紧急防暴训练，以为自己会被用大巴拉进城去平息局势。显然他们随后被告知原地待命。所以有许多——我相信这些最终都会被披露出来。但当时正在进行许多非常高层的战略对话。正如我们在一开始所说的那样，俄罗斯人从他们开始……”}🍦```[instruction] context: {
the uprising started in 53, the Russians withdrew their support under Gorbachev in 89 because Gorbachev had said, my troops are staying in their barracks. You're basically on your own. We are not going to get involved in this domestic fight. Soon as they knew that, they lost. I mean, I know you've talked to lots of people who are people in Stasi and people in the regime and stuff. Are there people you've talked to who think that they should have kept the wall up and that they were too weak in 1989? Absolutely. Yeah, yeah. I mean, I had a very, I wouldn't say surreal. I was hairs on the back of your neck time,
起义始于53年，在戈尔巴乔夫的领导下，苏联人在89年撤回了支持，因为戈尔巴乔夫曾说，我的军队会留在军营里，你们基本上得靠自己，我们不会卷入这场国内斗争。一旦他们知道了这一点，他们就失败了。我的意思是，我知道你和很多人聊过，比如斯塔西的人和政权里的人等等。有没有人跟你聊过，他们认为应该把墙留下来，他们在1989年太软弱了？绝对有。是啊，是啊。我的意思是，我有一种非常，我不会说是超现实的体验，那是让你毛骨悚然的时光，
but I was with one of the commanders. He'd literally grown up with Checkpoint Charlie. So he started as a private. And by 89, he was the commander of up with checkpoint Charlie. So he started as a private and by 89, he was a commander of checkpoint Charlie, Peter Bachman. And, uh, I was in his, there's a Northwest, uh, Hohenschonhausen is an area of North East Berlin. And it's where a lot of the elites, uh,
但我当时和其中一位指挥官在一起。他 literalmente 是在查理检查站长大的。所以他从一个列兵做起。到了89年，他成了查理检查站的指挥官。所以他从一个列兵做起，到了89年，他成了查理检查站的指挥官，彼得·巴赫曼。而且，呃，我在他那里，那是西北部，呃，霍恩申豪森是柏林东北部的一个地区。很多精英，呃，
of the border guards lived and they were given the best housing. It's still all there and they're all veterans now. And that's where they all live. It's like boys from Brazil almost. And so I was in his apartment and I felt like, it was like Deutschland, the series on Channel 4. I'm in this apartment and I felt like I was back in the 70s with all the decor, his armchairs, and all his photographs of him in his pomp,
边防卫兵就住在那里，他们得到了最好的住房。现在那里都还在，他们现在都是老兵了。那是他们住的地方。几乎就像是《来自巴西的男孩》里的情景。所以我在他的公寓里，我感觉，就像是第四频道的电视剧《德国八九年》。我在这个公寓里，我感觉自己回到了70年代，所有的装饰，他的单人沙发，还有他风华正茂时的照片，
all dressed up there. And he just gave me an hour and a half's education on why the East German experiment was successful, why his service meant something, why he was bitter about the outcome, why they needed more backbone and leadership, and why he felt betrayed about what his lot had now become, living in this flat in on the suburbs of east berlin and doesn't have a pension and just scraping by that kind of thing and he's not alone he's just one person i interviewed that's an amazing story um so the berlin wall come i mean it's vanished basically now hasn't it it's kind of got disassembled yeah i can understand why they yeah i can understand
盛装打扮的照片。他给我上了一个半小时的课，讲为什么东德的实验是成功的，为什么他的服兵役是有意义的，为什么他对结果感到痛苦，为什么他们需要更多的骨气和领导力，为什么他感到被背叛，因为他的同类现在变成了住在柏林郊区这个公寓里，没有养老金，只能勉强糊口这样的人。而且他不孤单，他只是我采访过的一个人。那是一个了不起的故事，嗯，所以柏林墙倒塌了，我的意思是，它现在基本上消失了，不是吗？它有点被拆解了，是的，我能理解为什么他们，是的，我能理解
why they wanted to get rid of it because it was an abomination and lots of people had died crossing it. But in some ways, obviously, as you guys know, it's such a pivotal moment in 20th century history. It would have been great if they just left a decent portion. That's what I was going to ask you.
为什么他们想摆脱它，因为它是一个令人作呕的东西，很多人在跨越它时丧生。但在某种程度上，显然，正如你们所知，这是20世纪历史中如此关键的一个时刻。如果他们能留下相当大的一部分，那就太棒了。这就是我要问你的。
I was going to ask you that. You see, I mean, we did a podcast, we did three podcasts a few weeks ago about statues in london about statues coming up staying down yeah my instinct is always to conserve and i look at berlin and the berlin wall and i know i'm not a berliner so i have no you know useful input into this at all and it's not my decision but part of me wishes it had stayed up that it was all still up and you could walk along in well there's a tiny bit of it there's not there's not there's not much of it and of course to a lot of people to a lot of people it is an obscenity and something they want to be what do
我要问你这个。你看，我的意思是，我们做了一个播客，几周前我们做了三个关于伦敦雕像的播客，关于雕像是留下来还是拆除，是的，我的直觉总是保护文物，我看着柏林和柏林墙，我知道我不是柏林人，所以我对这个完全没有什么有用的意见，这不是我的决定，但我的内心深处希望它能留下来，它仍然完好无损，你可以沿着它走，嗯，那里有一小部分，没有，没有，没有多少了，当然，对很多人来说，对很多人来说，它是一个耻辱，是他们想要除掉的东西，你觉得呢？
you think about it though in do you would you do is there a bit of you that wishes there was more of it still up well yeah yeah as a historian definitely i mean i i would have uh i think if you'd kept the a large section that ran through the central government section, the MITA section, middle section, which is where Checkpoint Charlie is situated and where the British sector was as well, so the Brandenburg Gate. I think if we kept that, that would have been really good from an education point of view more than anything else there are very small fragmentary sections of it that are there uh one of which is on the the uh the french sector and there's a there's a really lovely museum there too that's next to it and they've retained the watchtower so you can see but nearly pretty much all but one or two of the watchtowers and there's over 300 of them they've all gone there's one you can find in the central section of the city, and the locals call it Last of the Mohicans because that's the only one.
不过，你呢？你有没有一点希望它能保留更多呢？哦，是的，是的，作为一名历史学家，绝对是这样，我的意思是，我，我想如果你保留了穿过中央政府区（米特区，也就是中间区域）的那一大段，查理检查站就在那里，英国占领区也在那里，勃兰登堡门也在那里。我想如果我们保留了这一点，从教育的角度来看，这会是非常棒的。那里有一些非常小的零星碎片，其中一个在法占区，旁边还有一个非常可爱的博物馆，他们保留了瞭望塔，所以你可以看到，但几乎除了那一两座瞭望塔之外，所有的瞭望塔——有300多座——都消失了。在城市的中心区还能找到一座，当地人称它为“最后的莫希干人”，因为那是唯一的一座。
And there's an old guy there. He must be 90 at least. He sits on his deck chair waiting for a fee. He'll unlock the door and let you go up it. So I managed to do that. Would they not think of the tourist industry? What were they thinking? The thing is, Tom, it's like going to Edinburgh but uh would they not think of the tourist industry what were they thinking the thing
那里有一个老头。他至少有90岁了。他坐在沙滩椅上等着收费。他会打开门让你上去。所以我设法做到了这一点。他们难道不考虑旅游业吗？他们在想什么？问题是，汤姆，这就像去爱丁堡，但是，呃，他们难道不考虑旅游业吗？他们在想什么？问题是，
is tommy it's like going to edinburgh and you're you're you have an avalanche of harry potter memorabilia you go to berlin there is so much memorabilia of the wall you can buy for ridiculous prices i sometimes think they knocked the china the wall of china down yeah so i can see it from space, surely there are factories in China now producing Berlin Wall. Anyway, I can't thank you enough. It's been brilliant. Who needs the Berlin Wall itself when you've got your book?
汤米，这就像去爱丁堡，你到处都是哈利波特纪念品，你去柏林，你可以买到那么多价格荒谬的柏林墙纪念品。我有时甚至想，他们把中国长城拆了，对吧？这样我就可以从太空中看到它了。中国现在肯定有工厂在生产柏林墙。无论如何，我对你感激不尽。这太精彩了。有了你的书，谁还需要柏林墙本身呢？
Thank you. I can't thank you enough. Yeah, brilliant book. Absolutely brilliant human stories that we didn't get a chance to get into. Many, many thanks for that. It's an amazing story, isn't it? Yeah, thank you. It's still ongoing that um i mean it's an amazing story isn't it yeah thank you still ongoing i mean it's fascinating for for those of us who kind of grew up with it but i'm sure it'll be fascinating as well for people who live in a world where it just seems impossible to imagine
谢谢。我太感激了。是的，精彩的书。绝对精彩的人类故事，我们没有机会深入探讨。非常非常感谢。这是一个了不起的故事，不是吗？是的，谢谢。它仍在继续，嗯，我的意思是，这是一个了不起的故事，不是吗？是的，谢谢。仍在继续，我的意思是，对于我们这些伴随它成长的人来说，这很着迷，但我确信，对于生活在一个柏林分裂似乎完全不可想象的世界里的人来说，这同样会非常着迷，
that berlin was divided so the berlin wall has gone um but i guess in we have your book um checkpoint charlie um anyone who wants to know more about the berlin wall can't recommend it So the Berlin Wall has gone. But I guess, Ian, we have your book, Checkpoint Charlie. Anyone who wants to know more about the Berlin Wall can't recommend it highly enough. Fantastic read. Thank you so much for giving us your time, giving us your knowledge. We will see you soon with more historically themed podcastery. Auf Wiedersehen. Bye bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
柏林墙已经消失了，但我想，伊恩，我们有你的书《查理检查站》，任何想更多了解柏林墙的人，我都极力推荐它。非常棒的读物。非常感谢你抽出时间与我们分享你的知识。我们很快就会带着更多历史主题的播客与大家见面。再见。再见。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。